hello everyone my name is emily and
welcome back to sun sub a channel all
about how to survive in the online
jungle
so
cryptography what is it
well it's the basis of our digital
security for a start our smartphones and
laptops encrypt all the information they
store without us even noticing this
process of data conversion takes place
on the fly
every time we open a website starting
with the letters https we exchange
encrypted traffic wireless networks bank
payments ethereum smart contracts and
even video calls via zoom
all of these things depend on
cryptography
at the heart of encryption algorithms is
the creation of random keys however this
term random keys presents just a small
problem spontaneity is not one of the
strengths of your computer computers
worked according to strictly defined
algorithms and it's virtually impossible
for an algorithm to get an unpredictable
or genuinely random number although if
you think coming up with a random number
is easy don't celebrate your superiority
over machines too soon because you're
also not capable of it
[Music]
let's do a little experiment think of a
number between 1 and 10.
if i were to tell you that you're
thinking of the number 7 then i'd be
correct in 28 of cases
and if i suggested that you're thinking
of number 10 the likelihood of me
guessing correctly is less than 2
at least this is the claim made by
authors of the study i came across on
reddit a few years ago
they posed the same question to eight
and a half thousand students and
received the following distribution of
results
doesn't it look a lot like people
weren't actually able to come up with a
random number the fact is that their
choice was influenced by psychology
in western culture 7 is a lucky number
and some even consider it a magic number
our brain seeks positive emotions and
therefore even in such a simple
unimportant situation it's impossible
for us to trust it this approach might
not apply for just one person of course
each of us has our own lucky number but
the more people that participate in this
game the more likely it will be that
there appears predictable results with
the advent of computers this is only
worsened
the flying toasters look see they're
toasters and they're flying imagine
outside your window it's april 1995.
you sit at your computer slowly browsing
the internet on netscape navigator and
finally you decide on your first online
purchase you place an order for a book
by douglas hofstadter and enter your
personal details onto the site name
address your credit card number now
congratulations you've just made history
twice in fact firstly you placed the
first order on amazon.com
secondly you used an insecure encryption
protocol which by that time hackers had
already learned to crack to work over
the secure https protocol netscape
programmers use non-secure keys at first
glance a 40-bit key has about a trillion
possible combinations going through all
of them even on a modern computer is no
easy task but the problem was that they
weren't really random the generation of
these keys used the current time of day
and process id in the system this meant
that the number of possible combinations
was reduced by so much that it only took
about 30 hours for the attackers to find
these unbreakable keys the netscape
story illustrates the problem of
randomly generated numbers perfectly in
the majority of cases these random
numbers are in fact generated via some
complex mathematical transformations
from non-random numbers now these such
numbers are called the seed the
reliability of the entire cryptographic
algorithm depends on the choice of seed
values all the same in 1996 enthusiasts
created a wonderful site called lavrand
it would generate random numbers using
as the seed a photograph of a few
hundred lava lamps literally speaking
this was a beautiful solution the
labyrinth site existed from the start of
the 2000s but a few years ago this idea
was repeated by the guys at cloudflare
they installed 100 of these lamps in
their office in san francisco and now
they use these images to encrypt their
internet traffic in the singapore office
of the same company they use a more
classic method of generating random
numbers this technique involves using a
detector to record the decay of a
radioactive isotope each decay occurs at
a totally unpredictable moment in time
so the output is a truly random number
until recently such systems were only
used in really advanced information
systems for example those related to
bank payments but now you too can
assemble a similar device at your desk
so what expensive pieces of equipment do
you need to make it happen
well actually just an ordinary banana
now you might already know that this
fruit contains a radioactive isotope
potassium 40. its quantity is extremely
small but nuclear physicists in their
calculations like to measure small doses
of radiation in banana equivalents an
idea developed by an italian student
valerio nappy he assembled an isotope
decay counter using amateur components
and used bananas as a radiation source
if you're interested in giving this a
try yourself all schematics and project
code are available at hackaday.io you
can find a link to it down below in the
description now nathi's banana is a
truly random number generator as in the
case of larval amps the source of
randomness is outside of the computer
the program only captures and processes
data from the real physical world but
buying bananas every time you're going
to withdraw money from an atm or want to
chat with your colleagues over zoom
isn't the most convenient solution so
once again we have to find a compromise
between convenience and security hence
in programming most of the time we're
talking about pseudo-random number
generators
[Music]
take a look at this animation the white
pattern shows truly random numbers
whereas blue is the result of a
pseudo-random generator
see how the blue dots gradually add up
to a repeating pattern in addition all
pseudo-random number generators will
sooner or later start reissuing the same
values
this is called the period of the
generator for simple algorithms the
numbers will start repeating after just
a few thousand uses the most advanced of
the popular algorithms the merson vortex
operates with prime numbers in 623
dimensions and its period is practically
unreachable but unfortunately even this
vortex is not crypto resistant by the
way real randomness is not actually
always desired by users
apple programmers experienced this first
hand when the music shuffling function
worked genuinely randomly in the first
generations of the ipod customers
actually complained that their favorite
tracks appeared too rarely as a result
the algorithm had to be changed the
songs were given a rating and user's
favorites began to be included more
often than others in turn the customers
were satisfied with this new random
shuffling but anyway let's get back to
data protection how serious is the
problem of bad random number generators
let me tell you about one example
specialists at the company independent
security evaluators
carried out an analysis on the security
of the ethereum blockchain they searched
for keys that were generated with an
error and therefore were less resistant
than usual in the words of asia and
vednarick they were able to find 735
of these weak keys now experts also
noted that dozens of these were set up
to send money to the same recipient it
turned out that this method was being
used by an unknown hacker mistakes in
the generation of random numbers cost
ethereum users a minimum of
7 million dollars in december 2019 a
group of students from scotland saudi
arabia and america announced the
creation of a fundamentally new and
absolutely crypto secure system they
claim that the system is immune even to
the fantastic capabilities of quantum
computers and it was chaos theory that
helped them in their work
[Music]
guys i've got some news for you tony our
chief legal officer at sun sub just
launched another exciting interview this
time tony interviewed soroush kafiyavadi
director at kroll the world's leading
international financial investigator
soroosh is based in gibraltar and his
15-year long professional career is
tightly linked to financial crime
investigations and liaison with
financial regulators such as the fca in
the uk in this video he and tony discuss
how various risk factors should be
applied to risk management as well as
current changes in the risk status in
the global geopolitical environment and
his personal experience in anti-money
laundering it's a game of cat and mouse
[Music]
you've surely already heard about the
butterfly effect more than once or in
particular the popular phrase among
journalists that the flapping of a
butterfly's wing can cause a hurricane
on the other side of the world now this
phrase triggers in my imagination a
whole chain of events where a small and
insignificant action can lead to huge
consequences but as in the case of
schrodinger's cat the author of the
theory actually had something completely
different in mind in 1972 edward
lawrence a professor of meteorology from
mit almost forgot that he was supposed
to be giving a presentation at
conference he didn't even title his
report he just sent the thesis to the
organizers at the last moment the events
program had to be compiled without the
participation of the professor therefore
the author of the famous phrase was one
of the members of the american
association for the advancement of
science and a fan of ray bradbury's work
philip merenese
it was he who suggested the name of
lawrence's lecture does the flap of a
butterfly's wing in brazil set off a
tornado in texas it's worth noting that
this was a question and not a statement
at all in fact lawrence has been
modelling complex processes in the
earth's atmosphere for more than a
decade in the 60s climatologists were
just beginning to master computers the
behavior of airflows was determined by a
system of complex differential equations
calculations which took many hours one
day lawrence decided to recalculate the
data he'd received a few days earlier
he ran the program a second time and got
a completely different calculation now
it seemed impossible
the same program on the same computer
with the same data
but different results like a real
scientist lawrence repeated the
simulation once again
the results coincided with the previous
experience as was later discovered for
the first simulation the value of one of
the system parameters was set as
0.506127
and during repeated calculations the
professor just rounded it up to
0.506 and it wasn't just a simple
rounding error
the system in the climate model turned
out to be quite sensitive to changes in
the parameters minor changes
unexpectedly caused an avalanche of
consequences in the famous report
lawrence discussed his experiments using
a metaphor about the flapping of a
butterfly's wing but the essence of his
thesis was quite different firstly if
one wing stroke can cause a tornado then
all previous and all future strokes of
this butterfly as well as the strokes of
the other billion insects on our planet
are also capable of doing this and
secondly if one butterfly is capable of
causing a tornado then equally the same
wing flap can prevent a catastrophe in
other words a slight change in the
source data might go unnoticed
subsequently starting a tornado or
conversely stopping it and what we
usually mean by the butterfly effect is
actually more correctly called the
domino effect
when a small falling domino topples
others along the chain laura's developed
his ideas and created a new mathematical
discipline chaos theory he argued that
most fields of science deal with
predictable phenomena for example
chemical reactions or electrical
circuits but complex open systems are
chaotic that is they're virtually
impossible to predict the slightest
inaccuracy and we'll get an effect that
in programming is called garbage in
garbage out the hypersensitivity of the
chaotic system formed the basis of a new
cryptographic system
unique cryptographic keys in this system
are generated based on user fingerprints
but unlike the scanners we're used to
the pattern of the lines or friction
ridges as they're called of the
recipient and sender becomes the basis
for creating a one-time key which is
equal to the size of the message the
exchange of information about keys is
based on the same principle as in the
case of quantum data transmission we
talked about this in detail in the video
about the prospects and threats of
quantum technologies so if you're
interested in this topic be sure to take
a look in theory such a cryptosystem is
impossible to crack the key exchange
procedure is fully protected due to the
laws of physics and it's mathematically
impossible to choose a random key that
is equal to the length of the text on
the other hand the abilities of computer
technology scares me more and more every
day so you remember the story of
bradbury which was the origin of the
metaphor about the butterfly wing if
you're not familiar it's a story about a
time traveler who in the past steps on a
butterfly and this radically changes the
future in mid-2020 a group of scientists
from los alamos national laboratory were
able to repeat this experiment they
built a real time machine well okay
almost real in their work they used a
quantum computer and simulated sending
equipment the so-called unit of
information in such systems into the
past in the past this information was
corrupted and then returned to our time
but the results surprised scientists by
the time this qubit returned to our time
it had restored its original value it
turns out that the timeline in the
quantum model corrected itself it sounds
incredible
so you can travel to the past and
trample not only butterflies but also
dinosaurs and the future won't change in
practice this means just one thing
despite the fact that quantum
technologies are gradually entering our
lives we still don't fully understand
the structure of our world and besides
in 95 netscape's secret keys also seemed
absolutely reliable
so we'll have to wait and see
do you often check the weather forecast
and i don't mean for the next day or two
but for information about the weather at
least a week ahead the trouble is that
the weather forecast prediction for a
period far in the future is akin to
telling your fortune by reading tea
leaves chaos theory unequivocally
rejects the possibility of reliable
predictions at least a month in advance
even the most accurate present moment
changes turn any model into a complete
absurdity and if we can't predict the
weather then what about the future of
cryptography so far there are a lot more
questions than answers i wouldn't even
take for granted the statement about the
absolute security of any system imagine
for example that a quantum encryption
terminal is connected to a computer
that's been infected with a spyware
program how long will your secrets
remain secrets then therefore even if
scientists managed to create an
absolutely cryptographic data
transmission channel the most
significant unpredictable and chaotic
factor will always remain i'm talking
about us humans so
that is all for today guys my name is
emily and this is some sub and i look
forward to taking you on our next
expedition through the online jungle
[Music]